do you ever want to do it again
not chappelle show but like
no i don't you i you did i always try to
bring you
but you didn't you did an hour long
television show how was it oh god was it
fun was it how was your life we didn't
have a life no kidding yeah like it's
not it's like
this is too hard but is there other ever
a party that's like okay i want to
create another thing
that
captures cultural sentiment like that's
what excited me about the show that we
made right is like it felt like every
week
we were doing something and it was
before we did netflix when we were doing
it weekly on instagram i was like oh
every week
we tapped into the conversation right
and had like something really
interesting fun and like thoughtful
about it and it was really exciting and
you got to experience that like every
week
it was tuning in and people were
reacting imagine there was social media
imaginary it's the last show i remember
that you stopped down at that time right
you watched it isn't there is there a
part of you now i know
i'd rather just do stand-up and i don't
i was telling somebody earlier it's too
hard yeah
it's too hard so
if you have like a
group of dudes that you love doing it
with yeah that's makes it it makes it
easier and makes it more fun yeah but
at this point it's like
yeah what i don't even i it's like
peers-wise
it's like who am i
it's just all
dragons yeah it's like just too hard to
do and then
uh
even like sedakis i saw sedakis a couple
weeks ago and it was like yeah i got to
go back to la and i got to do the
writer's room and he just got back from
london for eight months and it's just
like
ah that doesn't look like it doesn't
seem like a fun life so you're yeah
you're valuing
enjoyment like first person like what is
my what is it yeah i when people bring
up travel show all i think about is like
i'm [ __ ] exhausted like i'm so i
wouldn't sleep
for three days yeah
i'd have to edit
like in the editing room for two days
straight yeah yeah not and then like i'd
have to
convince bijan to stay
the editor yeah and then
i would only go home
like to go to the bathroom yeah because
i have a no i don't do it outside of the
house yeah no i get it
you got it so uh
so i just all i think about is stress
that's literally all i think about is
like it's fear yeah it's like ptsd yes
pdf so the commercials are amazing
because the cards are great because it's
like
two days
i would say like it's your wedding where
do you want to stand yeah yeah yeah yeah
great yeah product shelf shoot the [ __ ]
out of this yeah gatorade i had gatorade
with lillard and damian lillard and
serena and just like great
go to portland got a [ __ ] palm beach
yeah serena's like yeah i'll be in your
gatorade you're coming to palm beach
great see you there portland do damien
like just
what have i done i do kev yeah chase
with kev yeah doing uh
i did a nba 2k
like the most recent one where where uh
what's his name
from boston
uh
jason tatum just playing video whatever
just like
it's just he's right i did sprite with
lebron yeah
no i hear you man it's just
i don't know i know i i you know the
feeling and not a lot of people know the
feeling i know the feeling and i also
know
it's exciting it's very exciting
exciting but i but then and we got a
fraction of what you guys experienced
yeah but we did experience it and we
experienced it in a down time where
there wasn't a lot of good things yeah
coming out so maybe it was it felt even
bigger because there was really no
competition yeah like we were putting
out a thing every week and there was
nothing new coming out and then the last
dance
yeah you know what i mean so it was just
like it was it was go time but you
experienced that on a [ __ ] crazy
level
and
i don't know i'm just curious if it's i
mean
it's just too it was it's too hard but
it is good it is a really fun thing
to
have an idea
say it
go yeah
and then you do it and do it and then
it's like yeah it doesn't even really
even you can't even track it has anybody
done it
with a realistic schedule like has
anybody created
the show apparently louie would only
shoot for eight hours really which is
like that's pretty good
but he wouldn't go on location scouts he
like he would just go like this he would
just do it he would edit himself he
wouldn't go on location like he just had
it honed to the point
where
like you it's it's humane
and also louis wasn't at the level that
we're talking like it was important for
some people he was i mean
of course but it wasn't it's different
to be important for some people and then
just to be important period yeah right
like chappelle show was like it crossed
over man yeah you had to see it so i was
like
yeah i remember hearing
somebody goes i was just in vain well
the cool thing was we did the taping
all right there was a there was a cut of
the first i would edit for i would be
[ __ ] dead yeah yeah and i would have
to bring a tape up i was this is how
[ __ ] long ago this was i would bring
a physical tape to 106 in park
and
so we showed
we showed like racial draft like stuff
that was done for the first episodes and
then i was like i have a kind of rick
james like it's not good like we worked
on it for three hours yeah and uh
we showed it and it's like uneven
cocaine's a hell of a drug got a lot the
repeat i like put a repeat in and that
gotta laugh and i was like all right
i'll do more of those
and then oh you got to try but it didn't
yes you got to work out there oh we'd
show it to caroline's
wow we would show sketches of caroline
you're working out the jokes within the
head yeah
we would do cuts i would we would do
cuts and then trell would do like
caroline's and then
go like i hear some sketches but it was
before the show was on so we were like
what
yeah what are you doing we in fact but
not even what are you doing we showed
the racial draft at the cellar i think
the night before we showed it and it
kind of ate [ __ ]
and david's like ah this is not the
right crop but so we showed a cut of
rick james and dave was like that was
that was the best we could something
like that was the best you can do and
he's this is like his favorite story
about me is i looked and when i went and
i look like [ __ ] like a wily coyote
like a vomit exploding my face i go yeah
sorry man
like just like [ __ ] i yes i failed
you again yeah with [ __ ]
by working [ __ ] my dick off and uh
but like and then we had the taping and
then dave's wife said she was at a
restaurant it hadn't aired yet and she
heard someone say i'm rick james [ __ ]
and that is over before it had aired
they had been at the taping oh from the
taping from the taping they just were
saying it
and then somebody said i was in vegas
and people the blackjack table were
saying i'm wrong james picture and my
first thought was like why
why would anyone say that and then and i
still don't really know why but i'm glad
they did is that when you realized how
big the show was that was the cool thing
about that was like the show was that
was on the fourth week
of the second season and the ratings
went up a hundred thousand people every
week after
like a weird like hundred thou like just
point one point two point three so we
got a million extra viewers in
uh
whatever however long that is in
ten weeks ten weeks and and then our
contracts were up of course now it's
game time yeah yeah
um so
so yeah so that was that was fun
yeah it's a it's a rare but i don't it's
not something uh okay how about this
question it was a spiritual thing that's
like
not even this is pre ayahuasca uh it's a
spiritual thing in that it's just like
we had been
it's just like a 10 years of like yeah
and then like boosh like [ __ ] was on the
show that we'd been talking about for
like the real world sketch we had talked
about in 10 years earlier
years ago
got thrown off yeah
because
i think what a lot of people don't
realize is like your first special
your first movie
squid game is a perfect example of this
is like you work 10 years for your first
album yeah 10 years for your first
special like everybody their first
creation is not made in that two-year
timeline that the rest of their
creations are made well by the way
that's why steve martin never did stand
up again he admitted it on seinfeld on
comedians this is my first life he's
like i would have taken me ten years to
write another hour yeah
rarely is the second album as good as
first on we somehow
hacked it a little bit
but maybe you had more wealth to give
still we yeah we did but also like
tucker pitched the racial draft brian
tucker
uh he writes for china live now okay
he's the what he's in uh
uh
i know black people he's like the
whitest looking dude you've ever seen
he's so [ __ ] white he's the one who
said uh
uh what is a lucy and he's like like a
like a ho
tucker pitched
a thing like we had donnell well i the
who keeping it real goes wrong it's kind
of me and donnell
like there were just hits that were like
kroll actually pitched the n-word family
oh really yeah kroll and berbiglia and
roger hales pitched that they pitched it
kind of like not how we did it yeah yeah
yeah and uh we they pitch it like a
sitcom or they pitch it like a
documentary in the moment so like we had
outside
but that it was mostly just about like
yeah not even butting heads just like
this thing yeah
and then you can
do you think you could do it again
though
like do you think if you had the
bandwidth if you had the time and if you
had the passion you weren't worried
about stress do you think it's a thing
that you could create
could you be part of a show
and make that show the thing to watch oh
i have no idea i don't i not not in a
way that like i know what to do it's
like a weird thing
where
it was dave's tenth pilot yeah so it's
like i hadn't worked on anyone but it's
a weird
thing where when you find
your genre yeah like
it was one of those things where
once we did it i was like oh you should
have been doing sketches the whole time
it feels like you don't even know
you don't know that as a when you're
yourself like yeah and then you try and
go oh i'm weirdly good at this this is
what i've always been doing yeah yeah
and then you start to look back at bits
and you guys killing themselves with the
babies yeah
yeah sketches right eddie murphy
actually told dave like you could write
movies
like because he's like the way your
jokes are they're like visual and like
there's cut twos
so you could write movies but it never
i don't know it never came up as like
sketch like sketches i don't know even
when we when he called me to do it was
like playboy after dark so it wasn't
like it became a sketch show was not
even supposed to be it's it's one of
those things where like
when when you're part of something
that's successful and you realize what
goes into it in order to make it that
successful when you see people who have
had multiple successes
your respect just has to go so like when
you look like a christian well i don't
even uh who no no
like when i look at nolan i go wait a
minute like almost everyone is amazing
and the ones that aren't amazing are
still like
pretty i would argue that nolan's it's
about him and his brother he has the
team it's him but him and his brother if
you look at all their movies
moment it's just some weird thing
between them
and he's
developed a visual style but it's about
it's like i call it this like this this
[ __ ] ineffable like i don't know it's
just the thing thing yeah i remember
somebody saying
somebody saw
before the show came out
somebody saw me and dave together and
was like something about you too
i was like no but you felt it like
aren't there people
where you're around them and you feel
funnier like yeah yeah and it's just for
whatever reason they get your [ __ ] you
can start to you know skip all ideas
yeah tags come out like yeah but that's
always like we're friends because we
would go like
in 1992 we would talk about you know i
mean like we were just friends and that
would talk about [ __ ] yeah and then
that's the that's the reason why i'm
wary of doing it's like i don't have
that
thing with anybody
right like you gotta you need that
before yeah you need like people ask me
all the time like we'll do whatever i
could get my i'd like to sh
but i don't feel that way i remember
watching the current episode the carb
season where they did the seinfeld
reunion and every time jerry and larry
are on camera together it's a wrap it's
[ __ ] magic and you just see this
chemistry and you're like god damn that
thing i don't think about seinfeld makes
sense the success of seinfeld sense
right there there's the one where
they're talking about they're like the
stage manager from evening shade or
something where they have inside jokes
jerry and larry that's on the show and
you're like i don't even know what the
[ __ ] they're talking about this is great
yeah i don't even know yeah
there's one argument about a booth in
one of the episodes and like somebody
comes and jerry and larry both have a
side of the booth and then they're just
arguing about who should let that person
sit next and says like yo i'm watching
the show yeah yes you just see the magic
right there yeah and that's what i
assume you're saying you had with you
where it's like
[ __ ] there it is so in order to create
that thing you need it
even if the thing's in you
it's like it's like uh
i say it's like i got an idea that's
burning a hole in my pocket like i have
to yeah yeah like the these shows i do
like three mics and the new one is like
starting to transition no no but it is
that's the thing where i am like i have
to say this yeah whether it's
whatever happens yeah
it's uh to to liken it to something and
stand up like you know the new joke that
you're working out that's actually good
and you know how like if you put it
three
jokes into the set those first two jokes
are like oh do i have to [ __ ] yeah
yeah
you're so annoyed with everything before
it yeah you just want to [ __ ] open it
you're like you guys are phonies
like you guys are [ __ ] phony yeah i
wrote you six weeks ago and you were
great but this is the guy yeah
i'm this is my new baby i don't even
give a [ __ ] you guys are so happy yeah
like get out of my set yeah like why are
you even here
i'm glad neil's not having kids
he gets a floor and be like why are you
here
yeah that's why
that's my impression that's my
impression my dad
uh yeah but you that's the exactly
or a joke that you know is right but it
doesn't hit yet and you're like i'll
keep tinkering yeah i have a joke now
i
wrote it in the new show i wrote it
i call chappelle i go
has anyone done this joke he goes you
pitched me that joke in 1993.
he's got like the lebron memory that's
crazy memory right yeah yeah
he absolutely has a lebron man really
[ __ ] beyond like i
in terms of like i recall and stuff yeah
yeah yeah his eye mine's very good and
his is like how
like how the [ __ ] can you
he there's a story i heard somebody told
me that
uh
tony morrison
[Music]
was at dave's high school
who's the not toni morrison uh the poet
uh maya angelou was it dave's high
school
and she
was saying one of her poems couldn't
remember and dave finished it for no
like just a [ __ ] he's got like his
brain is like put in the smithsonian
like [ __ ] crate his dad was his
parents are professors yeah yeah he's
got that thirst for knowledge it seems
like where he just always seems to be
reading yeah based on what he's saying
it's like oh you're incredibly well read
clearly yeah he's not even well it's not
even reading it's like it's just osmosis
yeah it's like [ __ ] he like how
you you hit something with the nolans i
didn't think about that
i knew obviously it's jonathan and
christopher yeah right
but
that team in order to make the magic and
then you look at people who have like
made consistent i don't care what some
people might say about like i'm a big
sandler fan but like yeah it's they've
had that team
this whole time and it's like putting
together these random parts to go make a
movie that's better than anything else i
mean that's to be honest you might say
that's why
like the marvel stuff is so impressive
it's because they will just quilt
together a team to make those movies
like okay you're the new director for
this one
absolutely and the story lines are sold
i think they plug it into a fairly
specific formula
uh
so he is kevin feig is his name feige
he's the north star and then he makes
sure everything below works
you